die größte bedrohung die vom weltall aus
geht ist wohl der unzählige
weltraumschrott darunter sind nicht nur
etwa 3000 aktive satelliten sondern auch
raketenteile und sogar eine discokugel
sie alle sind mit einer hohen
geschwindigkeit von bis zu 30.000
kilometern pro stunde unterwegs und das
unkontrolliert sie könnten die ganze
raumfahrt durch eine katastrophe stoppen
jetzt soll endlich gehandelt werden wie
was warum klicks um science-fiction hier
gibt's täglich faszinierende
wissenschafts videos abonniert den kanal
nur dann verpasst ihr nichts herzlich
willkommen das was da unsere erde rast
ist quasi eine müllkippe weltraumschrott
wird oft unterschätzt mit fatalen folgen
denn die gefahr wird immer größer nach
angaben des branchenverbandes hätte
light industry association hat sich die
anzahl der satellit mal in den letzten
fünf jahren um 50 prozent erhöht und
fest steht der weltraumschrott hat eine
gigantische zerstörungskraft schätzung
zufolge kreise mehr als 20.000 objekte
mit einem durchmesser von mindestens
zehn zentimetern um unseren planeten und
das unkontrolliert hinzu kommen etwa
750.000 kleinere müll teilchen die etwa
1 cm groß sind und von der erde aus
nicht zu erkennen sind sie sind eine
riesige gefahr und können dass kessler
syndrom auslösen dass unsere
zivilisation um jahrzehnte zurückwerfen
würde dass kessler syndrom startet durch
einen crash innerhalb von stunden werden
ein großteil der satelliten rund um die
erde zerstört als kettenreaktion
inklusive der internationalen
raumstation iss immer wieder schlittern
wir an dieser katastrophe vorbei es gab
bereits 200 kollisionen im orbit der
erde und jede produziert wieder neue
schrott teilchen zwischen geht man von
etwa 170 millionen trümmerteilen
insgesamt aus die um die erde stören wie
sind die moment quasi zeuge eines
kessler syndroms in zeitlupe
spektakulärer höhepunkt 2009 stoßen der
iridium 33 das iridium satellitentelefon
netzes gewicht eine halbe tonne und der
russische satellit cosmos 2251 zusammen
bei einer aufprallgeschwindigkeit von
rund 40000 kilometern
stunde bleibt von beiden satelliten
nichts mehr übrig außer 100.000
schrottteilen dabei wurde eine energie
von etwa zehn tonnen tnt sprengstoff
freigesetzt bedingt durch die höhe ihrer
umlaufbahn wird es wohl rund 100 jahre
dauern bevor die teile in der atmosphäre
verglühen und selbst solche kleinen müll
teilchen können große schäden
verursachen treffen müll teilchen auf
satelliten module kommt es zur kollision
die vorzeitige alterung der getroffenen
module ist nicht mehr aufzuhalten
doch das ist noch nicht einmal der worst
case den sind schrott teilchen von einem
zentimeter größe können satelliten auch
auf einen schlag komplett zerstören dazu
der chef der abteilung weltraumtrümmer
bei der esa heiner klinkrad wenn eine
aluminium kugel von gerade mal einem
zentimeter durchmesser auf einen
satelliten trifft hat sie die energie
eines mittelklassewagens der mit etwa 50
stundenkilometer in ihn hinein fährt
klar ist ohne satelliten sind sie
aufgeschmissen und können weder
telefonieren noch unser navi im auto
nutzen aber auch für raumfahrer kann
weltraumschrott gefährlich werden im
schlimmsten fall könnten dadurch sogar
flüge ins all unmöglich werden eben wenn
das kessler syndrom einmal ausgelöst
worden ist davor hatte ein nasa
mitarbeiter schon vor 40 jahren gewandt
bisher hatte man diese schrott teilchen
vor allem durch radare beobachtet um
gefährdete satelliten im fall der fälle
rechtzeitig um längen zu können doch
nicht nur forschungsteams weltweit
sondern auch unternehmen arbeiten an
anderen technischen möglichkeiten um
zumindest ein stück weit die kontrolle
über die gigantische menge an
weltraummüll zu erlangen
eine neue idee kommt vom kanadisch
us-amerikanischen satellitenbauer space
systems loral ss l und zwar plant die
firma eine art pannendienst für
satelliten bedarf es da denn wie gesagt
kreisen etwa 3000 in aktive satelliten
um die erde dazu ssl mitarbeiter älteres
da werden buchstäblich hunderte
millionen dollar zum fenster
hinausgeworfen
schon in zwei jahren will das
unternehmen ein unbemanntes raumschiff
losschicken es soll nicht nur in der
lage sein am defekte satelliten
anzudocken und sie zu untersuchen
es soll sie auch betanken und reparieren
können und die gewarteten satelliten
dann letztendlich zu dem wieder in die
richtige umlaufbahn bringen eine art
abschleppwagen ist auch von der firma
intel hat geplant die betreiber von 50
satelliten ist auch bei diesem konzept
soll an ausgefallenen satelliten
angedockt werden um sie dann wieder in
die richtige umlaufbahn zu wuchs hier
schon im kommenden jahr wird wohl ein
anderer testlauf starten und zwar plant
das japanische unternehmen es losgeht
mit hilfe eines magneten systems kaputte
satelliten und auch anderen
weltraumschrott zu erfassen
das programm von airbus heißt base tank
und verfolgt die idee alte satelliten
auf eine entfernung von 200 kilometern
zur erde zu schleppen und sie dort
verglühen zu lassen all diese
unternehmen wollen mit ihren großen
aufräumen plänen im all natürlich auch
großes geld machen und die chancen dafür
stehen gar nicht so schlecht die wartung
von satelliten bezeichnen einige schon
als die zukunftsbranche schlechthin denn
eine reparatur ist deutlich profitabler
als eine neue satellitenmission zudem
gibt es entsprechende auflagen die das
geschäft lohnenswert machen können
bereits seit 2008 fordert frankreich von
satellitenbetreibern maßnahmen zur
sogenannten der optimierung der
raumfahrzeuge sie müssen also für die
entsorgung der satelliten sorgen
und da für sie nicht einfach aufgeben
fest steht dass das problem angegangen
werden muss dazu fred kennedy von der
militärischen us forschungsagentur arpa
wir wollen keinen wilden westen zum
internet agency spaces coordination
committee adc gehören nicht nur die nasa
und die esa sondern auch noch zehn
weitere raumfahrtagenturen auch hier
wurden richtlinien zur vermeidung von
abfall durch die raumfahrtindustrie im
all vereinbart beispielsweise sollen
raumfahrzeuge bei ihren missionen
möglichst wenig abfall abwerfen und
zubehör
die adapter und abdeckklappe nicht mehr
einfach abtrennen auf unserer erde haben
wir übrigens mit einem nicht minder
schlimmen problemen zu kämpfen
plastikmüll machte erde inzwischen
teilweise unbewohnbar
gefährlich für mensch und tier wir
müssen etwas dagegen tun ihr könnt mir
dabei helfen abonnierten account get rid
of plastics auf instagram dafür hier
klicken
zwei dinge bewirkt ihr damit ihr sorgt
für reichweite für das thema und ihr
erfahrt was es alles für produkte ohne
plastik gibt ihr könnt also helden sein
und das ganze unterstützen hier klicken
mitmachen ansonsten
dann bleibt dran